how do we feel about throwing the candle
we okay with that all right I thought
I'm not worried about you it's it's just
candle in the place time yeah you know
the famous Elton John talk go for it hey
GQ I'm will Poulter and these are my
essentials
[Music]
so for me in my 10 essentials I think a
pair of sneakers or trainers depending
on what side of the Atlantic you're on
had to make it in and possibly my
favorite pair I'm wearing
take it off seek a better look so this
is part of the 10 which was Virgil ah
blows Mikey collaboration which i think
is like maybe the most legendary sneaker
collaboration in history this is his
take on the mike zoom fly and it's just
crazy the materials knots and it's got
his kind of iconic sort of sonography on
it I'm super pedantic about him getting
like dirty I have like cleaning products
for that and stuff and specially
assigned toothbrushes and it's a full
like geeky thing that I'm committed to
me this is notes on a nervous planet
which was kind of a life-changing read
just an amazing piece of writing on kind
of managing your mental health it's just
a beautiful book it structures really
unique as well like there are pages
there where it's just like you know a
little kind of haiku or something or
it's it it just says when anger trolls
the internet looking for a hook it's
time to disconnect and go read a book
just cool it's just one page it's a
little kind of I don't know a book with
this kind of much positive social
application is is definitely an
essential and I recommend picking up
nice catch
nice
so yeah an absolute like wardrobe
essential the the plain black tea I
probably have as like this block colored
teas I take ten that I kind of rotate
through it's more in control than my my
sneaker collection if you're gonna be
wearing a white t-shirt as well I think
a certain amount of weight is important
so you're not showing off your nipples
when you don't necessarily want to be I
love this one it's just super heavy way
yeah I often just wear plain black tees
para jeans and a pair of Nikes and
that's kind of like how I live
thank you thank you
headphones are an essential for me
because I get so much enjoyment out of
what I what I listen to
there a podcast or an away your book or
you know music I prefer these of the
chunky headphones just because it's easy
to maneuver around and you know the
active still with with these in music
wise right now I'm listening to a lot of
little Sims we love slow ties new album
Travis Scott came and Paula I'm excited
about myself about their new stuff we
were just listening to Liz OH
oh the wireless ones yeah I know
do you know I'm always behind with
technology like everyone's got you know
that up on the latest upgrade or model
of something and I'm always maybe a year
or even more behind probably should get
the wireless ones that would make it
even easier so yeah so I listen to like
a bunch of things through the headphones
and definitely an essential for me
[Music]
seamless okay so this is the the milk
bar pie from the famous milk bar that I
believe originated in New York and it's
from the genius mind of Christina Tosi
this thing is possibly the most
beautiful mistake ever made I think I'm
sort of paraphrasing her in that I think
she made what came to be known as crack
pie and it is so delicious it's a joke I
got to have a bite of it because the
last time I had it was was in New York
and you can only get it in the States
but look like just come on it's just I
mean it's so unhealthy couldn't be more
bad for you but but but also great for
you
like that is stupid it's too good to
throw this is the most precious thing
that we've been through actually so I'm
gonna have to pass this off gently thank
you my wear contact lenses but I also
wear glasses and these are awesome brand
called Zach created I believe by a by
someone who used to be an optician you
can kind of customize them and get
different sort of frames and lenses and
all kind of included in the price and I
just love them I love that the clear
frames and these have transition lenses
in them so when you're indoors they're
clear and then you go outside and they
go dark and they function as sunglasses
that's why I love you got to be careful
because if you go indoors having been
outside you've got to be aware that you
spend like five minutes indoors looking
like you're wearing sunglasses inside
and kind of makes it like an [ __ ] so
watch out for that I actually got a text
from a friend who said that a friend of
theirs had seen me on the underground
tube wearing sunglasses and I was like
oh no I was it was because it was like
outside and I felt very self-conscious
about that but um yeah they're just
beautiful glasses
[Music]
so another essential the Karma which is
foursome again for like mental health
purposes there are kind of like little
sort of guided meditations on here short
little exercises you can do songs that
are kind of designed to sort of bring
calm to your life and I'm also really
bad sleeper this has kind of things on
it they're really helped with that too
you can fall asleep to like rain on
leaves for example which is this you can
download calm from your app store so a
football or soccer ball again depending
on what side of the Atlantic you're on I
like football it's kind of a I guess
it's kind of the only sport really that
I played and continue to play it's
something that I always try and have in
my trailer on set so it's an essential
when falling off when I'm working just
for like a break from working and I've
like kicked this around with nearly
everyone that I've worked with the South
midsummer I was kicking us around with
the bloody Jack trainer and my pal
actually made that way when we were
shooting Bandersnatch a lot was kicking
this around with dysentery and my head I
love football I'm a big Arsenal fan
which can be tough I love them despite
all the pain they put me through yeah I
can't really I can't really sort of
imagine not being able to kind of kick a
ball around if I was on set I don't know
what I'd do myself so like a candle in
the face this is a candle the APC APC
the amazing French clothing brand this
is their big candle it's a beautiful
smell it's um it's amazing
candles are kind of an essential because
I find when I cook like my place just
smells like whatever I cooked unless I
burn a candle afterwards and also with
with the dog occasionally there are
mistakes made and the candle comes in
handy as far as covering up those
mistakes but it are it's the best smell
in the world
another essential for me is a canvas bag
for environmental purposes you know
going to the store or whatever always
try and remember to bring my canvas bag
and I have one from project zero who are
a really amazing ocean conservation
organization they sell like a range of
products the proceeds of which go
towards what they do you can go to we
are project zero org and you can get a
range of kind of environmentally
friendly products I think using a canvas
bag is one of those things so that's an
essential whenever I want to go buy
groceries I take my canvas bag with me